the wheels of britain's economy are
still rolling
even through a recession covid and
brexit and now
the vaccination program has provided a
glimmer of hope also says the bank of
england
the vaccine program is obviously
excellent news
and we do think that that is going to
support a sustained recovery throughout
the rest of the year
after really the end of the first
quarter so after the end of march and
that is obviously good news
thanks to the vaccine the bank thinks
that even though we're in another
lockdown
the economy should still recover to its
pre-covert levels by the beginning of
next year
for this business in cumbria which makes
biodegradable wrappers for confectionary
and other foods
that's promising news certainly those
those market sectors where we're
delivering into
hospitality cafe hotel
restaurant type applications they have
to improve they can't they can't
possibly be worse
rowena's shop in soho has been closed so
long the door had warped shut
even with the vaccine she's not
expecting things to pick up now till
autumn
and she says she relies on business
support being extended if her shops to
survive
because this has been so hard and it's
really going on for so long
it gets to a critical breaking point
access to funding through 2021 is going
to be really important
and our overheads are really important i
mean i'm facing a cliff edge in march
if they don't extend the rates really
for uh for retailers and small
businesses
that's going to be critical i do not
want to make any more redundancies
with businesses struggling and interest
rates already at rock bottom
governor andrew bailey says he wants
banks to be ready for negative interest
rates where the bank could conceivably
pay to lend people money though that
seems unlikely
actually the underlying message from the
bank today is not that the next move in
interest rates is likely to be down
but it might actually be up why because
vaccinations are increasing and the
economy is expected to get going again
later this year which
raises a question when to lift lockdown
and
just like we had last summer there's
likely to be another
battle between scientists who want to
keep those restrictions in place
and the business people and politicians
who want to reopen
the high street and the wider economy
chief among them chancellor richie
sooner
he's currently planning next month's
budget and is said to be keen to get the
economy going again
as cases fall and good news starts to
outweigh the bad the pressure to reopen
is only going to build ed conway sky
news